how do you hope the war in Ukraine comes
to an end and what's the path once again
to minimizing human suffering
there uh well I think that what what is
likely to happen uh which is really
pretty much the the way it is is that um
something very close to the
current lines uh will
be how a ceasefire or truce happens
but you know you just have a situation
right now where whoever goes on the
offensive um will suffer casualties at
several times the rate of whoever's on
the defense um because you've got uh
defense and death you got minefields uh
trenches anti-tank defenses um nobody
has air superiority um because the the
anti-aircraft missiles are really far
better than the the aircraft like they
far more of them um
and uh so neither side has air
superiority um tanks basically death
dfts um just slow moving and they're not
immune to anti-tank weapons M so you you
really just have longrange artillery um
and uh infantry trenches it's World War
One all over again
MH with drones you know throwing little
Dron some some drones there um which
makes the long range artillery just that
much more accurate and better and so
more efficient murdering people on both
sides mhm yeah so it's who who whoever
is you don't you don't you don't want to
be trying to advance from either side
because the probability of dying is
incredibly High um so in order to
overcome
uh defense in depth trenches and
minefields you really need a significant
local superiority in numbers um ideally
combined arms where where you you do a
fast attack with
aircraft a concentrated number of Tanks
um and a lot of people that's the only
way you're going to punch through a line
and then you're going to punch through
and and then not have reinforcements
just kick you right out again I mean I I
really recommend people read uh World
War I Warfare in detail
that's
rough
um I mean the sheer number of people
that died there was
mindboggling and it's almost impossible
to um imagine the end of it that doesn't
look like almost exactly like the
beginning in terms of what land belongs
to who and so on but on the other side
of a lot of human
suffering death and destruction of
infrastructure yes I mean the that the
reason I I you know proposed a a some
sort of Tru or or peace a year ago was
because I predicted pretty much exactly
what would would happen uh which is a
lot of people dying for basically almost
no changes in
land um and this the the loss of the the
flower of Ukrainian and Russian Youth
and we should have some sympathy for the
the Russian boys as well as the
Ukrainian boys CU they Russian boys
don't don't ask to be on their front
line they have to be
so
um there's a lot of sons not not come
back to their parents you know and
and I think most of them don't don't
really have they don't hate the other
side you know it's sort of like is this
saying about like this saying comes from
World War I it's like young boys who
don't know each other killing each other
on behalf of old men that do know each
other
the hell's the point of
that so Vladimir zalinski said that he's
not or has said in the past he's not
interested in talking to Putin directly
do you think he should yeah sit down
manto man leader to leader and negotiate
piece look I think I would just
recommend do not send the flower of
Ukrainian youth to be to die uh in
trenches uh whether he talks to Putin or
not just don't do that um whoever goes
on the offensive will lose massive
numbers of
people
um and history will not look kindly upon
them